hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my avatar last airbender book 1 Episode 5
video the king of Omashu as much as this is an episode about King
Bumi I think we all remember it mostly
as the first appearance of cabbage Corp
pork cabbage man all he wants to do is
sell those cabbages in the context of
the series I feel like they made this
episode wanting it to be able to exist
on its own like you could you could air
it anywhere and people would be able to
pick it up pretty fast just like a fun
side adventure but I feel like the
serialized episodes like the ones the
tie back to the main plot a lot more are
more rewarding so just careful for
spoilers as we start talking about top 5
moments and specific stuff from the
episode although I feel like you guys
are probably all seen these by now
starting with number 5 welcome to Omashu
city of super slides and rock candy I'd
say it's also the birthplace of cabbage
Corp but I don't think that we know the
cabbage Corp originated here I think the
way they blow that into the DNA of the
show is that there's always been a
cabbage Corp at one time or another like
it's a family company that gets passed
down from parent to child over and over
there's actually a whole lot going on
here like when they make that opening
reveal it looks a lot like Omashu might
be built on the back of a lion turtle I
do think whenever they made the avatar
want episodes they visually tried to
call back to that but Omashu itself is
in the wrong place to have been built on
a lion turtle so if you remember during
the avatar Wan episodes the lion turtle
that avatar Wan lived on top of was the
firebending one so that was probably
located somewhere in the modern day fire
nation the earthbending lion turtle was
actually in the desert so they'd be
located much closer to Washington's
library and then we finally meet the
illustrious cabbage band who is just
getting dumped on by everyone
sometimes I wonder when Mike and Bryan first started telling jokes like this
this is book 1 so this is the first time
they ever did this with cabbage man I
wonder if they felt like it was so funny
that they just kept doing it it takes so
long to make episodes like this to
animate episodes that they wouldn't have
gotten any feedback from the Phantom at
the time like maybe by the time they got
to book 3 when they were on book 3 they
probably had an idea of stuff that
people really liked but by the time
people were watching this episode they
were probably already rolling through
production on book - I feel like Aang's
this guy's here - is one of his
better-looking disguises we'll call this
the Appa hair mustache disguise the
interior the city is pretty cool-looking
obviously the first thing you think when
you see this is theme park like is this
a waterslide is it a roller I don't understand I feel like if avatar
had become as big a hit as spongebob is
they totally would have turned that into
a theme park moving on to number four
meet king bumi what a coincidence that
this person happens to be named just
like Aang's future child I also like
that they made Aang's son act a lot like
king bumi both of their characters were
way over the top just in the best
possible way this is where the episode
starts to drag a little too I mean the
premise is solid Ango back to a familiar
place reconnects with an old friend but
I feel like there's just not enough
going on in this episode they do get in
a couple of nights jokes I really liked
all the costs that they added after the
bad jokes like the running bad jokes
were pretty good usually that sokka's
territory but Bumi landed some pretty
good bad jokes Kangaroo Island for
instance that's actually that's a real
island off of Australia some of the
logic with the feast and the trials is a
little fuzzy but watching it now after
having watched all of Avatar it's a lot
funnier because you see these moments
where Bumi is like I'm the most powerful
vendor or you'll ever meet and it's like
dot yeah well yeah till you meet the
blind bandit or like when they get
locked up overnight here it's like where
is tough when you need her oh wait we
haven't met her yet like I said I think
this episode was designed more to tell
some of Aang's backstory and be like a
fun side adventure but but I feel like
it's just a bunch of gags kind of mashed
together with like a moral at the end
and it didn't quite work out the way
they wanted it to but it's still fun to
watch on to number three Aang has to get
Bumi's key this was actually my favorite
challenge even though their fight later
in the episode was a bigger deal he has
to find a way to get to the key without
being able to waterbend or Earthbend this is where we get some
real character progression usually what
you want is to have the characters face
a challenge that they can't overcome
without gaining new knowledge or
learning a new ability so I guess you
could say that Bumi's challenges were
one to just have some fun with and mess
with him a little bit and to to try and
teach him something of value it was kind
of the same deal whenever Korra went to
learn from Toph in the swamp
earthbenders very powerful very good
teachers but just super mean I kind of
wonder how much tops character flowed
from the DNA of Bumi's character but
they both have a really cynical
sarcastic sense of humor and they both
love to play pranks on people I think
part of the reason why top works so much better as a character it's just because
they had that much more time to figure
the series out like this is still
book 1 the first couple of episodes
they're still trying to figure the
characters out figure out the tone of
the show but on to number 2
anger sees Bhoomi this is a really good
fight but it also makes you really
appreciate the level of complexity that
they got to in Legend of Korra like
watch this fight and then go watch core
vs kuvira in the book 4 finale
Aang does show off a couple new moves
like the air tornado for instance but
there's this really cool Bhoomi ability
that I don't remember us ever seeing
again so this move here
whatever he falls backwards into the
sand and then earth bent himself up to
the platform underneath the ground does
anybody remember them using this move
again part of me thinks that they saw
this on screen and thought that it might
be a little too powerful so that
whenever they got to top they're like
okay she'll be really strong but we're
going to deep our her a little bit so that
she's more balanced with the other
characters it's like playing Warcraft
when they have to nerf DPS for a certain
class just because certain abilities
certain combos give them too much more
power and give him unfair advantages
over other classes Mike and Bryan made a
really big deal about bending making
sense in the Avatar universe like they
wanted it to flow from a logical place
so like even even the Avatar can push
themselves so hard that they died from
exhaustion
I think they said that that was just
their response to watching other
cartoons and seeing characters use
powers in ways that didn't make sense at
all within the internal logic of the
show you guys could let me know if you
agree but if you watch other animated
shows or other anime shows do you feel
like they're just as internally
consistent with the way powers work
sometimes it feels like the only shows
that really take themselves that
seriously or dramas and most cartoons
are not dramas and finally my number one
moment and finally reconnect with Bumi
and he reminds him about his mission to
learn all the elements and defeat Ozai
whenever Bumi mentioned ozai's name is
actually the first time that the Fire
Lord was given a name in the Avatar
series you have to remember this is only
episode 5 so it actually hadn't been on
for that long plus they get to go on
under the sled ride smash them more
cabbages they actually use cabbage man
three times in this episode I feel like
that's still the record let me know
though what was your favorite moment
from the episode and here's my big
question for you do you feel like when
they made this episode they hadn't quite
nailed down the show yet like by the
time they got to the end of book 1 the
beginning of book 2 they just they'd
figured things out just a little bit
better that's why you have to give him
giant high-five just because all of this
was built from the ground up all the
lore all the mythology it wasn't like
they were adapting Tolkien or some other
book or even a comic book that's why you
don't see that a lot nowadays just
because it's so hard to build original
IP and not even that if you can sell a
network on an original idea then you
have to build the universe out that
takes multiple seasons to do like a lot
of times usually if I'm talking about a
show as someone else I'll tell them to
start in like season 2 or season 3
because usually by that time the writers
have nailed the characters down and in
the show itself works a lot better of
course then you have some shows that get
to like seven eight nine seasons and
they totally jump the shark and
everything goes off the rails that's
actually another really good question
too when for you guys did Avatar The
Last Airbender become an amazing show
like were you hooked from episode 1 or
did it take you to a book to to you'd
like fully drunken the kool-aid just for
me making youtube videos has really
changed the way that I interact with
shows because it's much more of a social
experience now and when I was first
watching a lot of this stuff I didn't
have Twitter I didn't have a YouTube
channel
I was I was kind of experiencing it in a
vacuum all by myself I don't think
tumblr even existed then and that's
really where the avatar fandom lives
it's just once there is a community of
people for you to interact with like we
do have right now it's just so much
easier to get into a show just because
you have that shared social experience
that actually reminds me since this is a
new avatar video there's a new round of
the giveaway congratulations to lumpy
rocks you are the winner of this week's
Amazon gift card it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card so please message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact info because we don't have
Constantine anymore because it's not
ticking up my Friday nights it should be
easier for me to get out weekly avatar
videos again we're kind of rolling into
Game of Thrones territory but that's
like a Sunday thing so that's not going to
get in the way of this don't worry
though regardless of when new avatar
videos post I'll still be doing
giveaways in each one so no worries
there while you guys wait for the next
one you can click here for the rest of
my have't our bonus videos and you can
click here to learn all about the Black
Panther movie in phase 3 in Marvel phase
3 thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I'll see you guys tonight!